There are so many hidden secrets and strange
happenings that go down in the final scene
of Carrie, so stick around to the end of this
video if you want to see me analyse it.
This video is sponsored by Privacy.com, who
are offering a few new product options, so
keep watching to learn more.
And as a special treat for my Things You Missed
viewers, you'll get $5 to spend on your first
purchase - free money that you can use to
purchase anything online!
Go privacy.com/CZsWorld to sign up now.”
[INTRO]
I’ve covered the Stephen King universe a
lot here on this channel, but one thing I’ve
yet to do is take it back to the creation
of this universe.
I’m not talking about Gan, the almighty
being in King’s writing, I’m talking about
when King himself actually created the universe
by writing his first novel, Carrie, which
was published in 1974.
The first movie adaptation would come out
two years later, so let’s get into the Things
You Missed.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
The movie begins in Carrie’s gym class,
where we learn she’s basically an outcast
among her classmates.
She showers alone in the locker room after
all the other girls have cleared, but in the
background, there is a poster advertising
the Senior Prom, to take place on May 25th
and later become the climactic scene of the
movie.
The poster is light blue with text printed
on cloud designs, and it would be the rainlike
downpour of water sprayed by Carrie using
her telekinesis, that sparked the electrical
equipment and started the tragic fire at the
prom.
The poster’s color scheme, light blue and
white, comes up again and again to symbolize
an innocent purity.
For example, Carrie goes into the prom without
having ill intentions, and the place is decorated
with a light blue color scheme, but the kids
who are trying to sabotage her are wearing
red, which is explained by Carrie’s mother
to be the color of the devil.
"Red. I might've known it would be red."
...and when Carrie is humiliated, she changes
all the lights in the room to red.
Other examples of the good vs. evil color
scheme can be seen throughout.
Ms. Collins is dressed in light blue
when she saves Carrie from the bullying girls.
Carrie wore a light blue dress while walking
home after being victimized, wore light blue
to school the next week as she rejoins classes
and compliments Tommy Ross on his poem, Tommy
picks her up in a light blue car before Prom,
an event that was Sue Snell’s way of making
up for the bullying that occurred, and Carrie
changes into a blue gown after attempting
to wash away the evil symbol of the blood
after the prom.
On the other hand, red manifests itself as
evil, like the red blood that marks the beginning
of Carrie’s womanhood and the truck that
approaches the house then Tommy asks her to
the prom, both of which her mother sees as
sinful.
In the book, the prom dress is red, but in
the film, it’s pink, but Mrs. White still
labels it as the color of the devil.
Obviously there’s the blood that gets dumped
on Carrie at the prom, but there’s also
the red car that Billy Nolan uses to try to
run her over at the end.
The quilt at Sue’s house at the end is a
mix of reds and light blues which, like the
novel’s ending, suggests nothing has really
been solved.
Aside from the symbolism of colors, there
is also a good deal of symbolism for adulthood.
Remember, Carrie’s entire manic telekinesis
episode is powered by the stress of getting
her period, reaching adulthood and going on
dates; which alone is fine, but the stress
is multiplied by the humiliation caused by
her classmates.
So I think it’s no mistake that the shower
scene that kicks this all off features a very
adult oriented nozzle head and is filmed in
an almost sensual way.
Also, it is right after Carrie literally drops
the soap that she becomes extremely vulnerable.
If you don’t know what I mean, just Google:
“drop the soap.”
The gym teacher that helps her is Ms. Collins.
Her name is changed from Ms. Desjardin in
the novel, apparently just because it’s
easier to pronounce.
This is also the first film role for Betty
Buckley, who I’m a big fan of for her work
in Split and The Happening.
When Carrie gets ready for the dance, we see
a newspaper clipping by her mirror celebrating
Tommy Ross for winning the “player of the
year award.”
It's implied that he plays multiple sports,
but this seems like the most generic thing
ever. I mean, it could refer to the fact that he
essentially has two dates in the movie, his
girlfriend Sue, and his prom date, Carrie.
Then there’s this strange scene Carrie’s
mother, who has sworn off sex as a sin, is
scene mutilating this carrot, which would
be seen as another phallic symbol.
There are a couple more at the prom, outside
of this part, where I’m not really sure why this
much older English teacher is looking at the
young, first-year gym teacher like that, but
I’ll ignore that and focus on the curious
change from the book.
In the novel, Carrie starts destroying the
gym by causing the emergency sprinklers to
go off, but in the film it’s a much more masculine
image, in that she uses the ability to spray
the fire hose to ignite the chaos.
There’s one more motif that manifests itself
time and time again over the course of Carrie’s
runtime: the religious symbols that are craftily
sewn in to many of the scenes.
Let’s start with the devil references this
time.
The movie that Tommy and Sue watch when he
agrees to ask Carrie to the prom is a 1966
film called Duel at Diablo.
The house that Carrie lives in with her mother
is designed to look like a church.
Mrs. White mail orders her own
crucifix after deciding that the Baptist Church
in town participated in the ways of the devil,
but the movie takes it a step further with
it’s arching doorways and massive Leonardo
DaVinci painting.
When Carrie returns home after her rampage,
she returns to the sound of church music,
...and the smell of burning flames from candles that
her mother has placed all over the house,
including on the bed.
I too like to live dangerously, that’s why
I live in California.
The house represents a sanctuary for Mrs.
White, but just outside of it’s walls is
where evil lurks, as seen by the parking spot
indicator that resembles an inverted cross.
Mrs. White meets her fate when she ends up
being crucified after trying to take down
her daughter who she believes to be an agent
of the devil.
There’s more in that final scene, but I’ll
tackle that all together when I come back
with more Things You Missed.
Making purchases online has become the new
normal, it’s so easy, but a lot of the time
I forget to think about the merchants and
their data partners who can see our personal
information whenever we make a purchase.
I’ve been using Privacy.com to protect
me.
They make it super easy to protect your financial
life online by generating virtual card numbers
that hide your real bank information.
They also let you set limits on each virtual
card to protect you from unwanted charges
going through.
What they give you for free is awesome.
You can create up to 12 virtual cards per
month.
They’ve also just introduced two new plans.
The “Pro” plan is $10/month, gives you
everything from the free plan, plus 1% cashback
on all purchases, 36 cards/month and even
more security and privacy features.
Teams and small businesses, are obviously better
off on the “Team” plan.
It’s $25/month, gives you access to everything
from the Pro version plus DEDICATED account
management, 60 cards/month and transaction
limits tailored to your business needs.
If you go to my link, privacy.com/czsworld,
you’ll get $5 for free.
If you’re not gonna take five free dollars,
what are you even doing with your life?
Privacy.com/CZsWorld.
When Tommy and Carrie walk into the prom,
the band is playing a song whose lyrics sing,
“The Devil’s Got Ahold of his Soul.”
The song is called Education Blues by Vance
or Towers, and if you flip the gender of the
subject of this tune, it could easily be interpreted
to be about Carrie White.
Let’s roll it.
“As I look back upon my younger daze, I
really was a maniac.
Blowing up a john with a cherry bomb, Gave
the janitor a cardiac.”
It’s talking about a school aged kid who
doesn’t fit into societal norms and subsequently
goes on
a rampage.
“The teachers would say, ‘They should
lock him away And throw away all of the keys’
-- please!”
In Carrie’s case she has a reputation around
the school, causing constant bullying and
graffiti reading “Carrie White burn in hell.”
“He's outta control, The devil's gotta hold
of his soul!"
Obviously a reference to Carrie’s mom believing
that she’s an agent of the devil.
Also uncoincidental I’m sure, is Tommy Ross’s
reasoning behind voting for themselves for Prom
King and Queen.
“Come on. To the devil with false modesty.”
The prom itself is a very foreign thing to
Carrie, and I don’t think it would be too
much of a stretch to call an event centered
around social interaction to be very alien
for her.
Not you.
We’ll cover you one day.
But the prom scene is filmed as if it truly
is another planet from the theme, Love Among
The Stars, to Carrie describing her experience
to Ms. Collins,
“It's like being on Mars.”
to the shot of Carrie and Tommy dancing where
they spin on an axis as the camera orbits
around them, much like a solar system.
Also, we’re not gonna ignore the fact that
there are clearly Dragon Balls on stage,
right?
Vegeta, how many Things You Missed in Carrie?
“It’s over 9”
But before we look any further into the prom
scene, let’s discuss how it was setup.
When Carrie is sitting in English class there
are a couple of things to note, the first
of which is poster for Hamlet, the Shakesperian
tragedy known for… spoiler alert even though
it came out 420 years ago... the fact that
nearly everyone dies in the end.
The shot with both Carrie and Tommy in frame
utilizes something called a split focus diopter.
Let me explain.
The foreground and background are sharp and
in focus, but the middle ground is not.
Normally, this effect would be impossible
to achieve because in cinematography, you
can only have your focal length set to one
position at a time, just as under the normal circumstances
of high school culture, Tommy and Carrie would
never go out on a date.
But director Brian DiPalma uses this device,
the split focus diopter to set different focal
lengths for the left and right side of the
image, just like how under extraordinary circumstances,
Tommy and Carrie are together.
You can see it in some other DiPalma films,
but it’s honestly a bit dated, today if
we wanted to achieve that, we’d probably
use a greenscreen.
Not that I’d know anything about that.
The name of the high school has been changed
from Ewen High School in the book to Bates
High School in the film.
I think this was an homage to the classic
horror film, maybe the most classic of all
horror films, Psycho, which takes place at
the Bates Motel.
The music that accompanies Carrie’s use
of her powers…
Is very similar to the score from Psycho.
[clip]
And of course, both movies feature iconic shower
scenes.
The mascot of Bates High School is the Stingers,
a hornet like creature.
In film music terminology, a stinger is a
short sound used for emphasis,
"EMPHASIS!"
much like the
Psycho inspired sound I just mentioned.
That might be why Bates’ mascot is the Stingers.
The idea comes back during Carrie’s meltdown
at the prom where she sees in kaleidoscope
vision, something commonly associated with
how a hornet might see the world.
In this scene, Carrie is essentially an angry
hornet whose classmates have just shaken up
her nest.
There are a couple easter eggs referencing
obscurities from the book.
One of the nominees for Prom Queen is Cora
Wilson, who we can assume is one of the Wilson
sisters mentioned earlier by the coach.
"Watson? And the Wilsons?"
The Wilson Sisters are assumed to be adapted
from the Thibodeau sisters in the novel, a
pair of twins who partake in the bullying
of Carrie.
In the movie, Cora is seen dancing with this
guy, who may or may not be her date, Frank
Green but is definitely credited as “The
Beak.”
Now in the novel, The Beak is a boy named Freddy
Holt.
He’s only mentioned once; he’s the first
name that pops into the principal’s head
when he hears that Carrie White is going to
prom.
The novel says he’s a misfit for his huge
nose and small frame, but the movie gives
him his own awkward charm.
"Wait a second, I know just the tuxedo for him."
"Well what do you think, huh?"
"I like it. I think it's terrific."
"Look at that. No ruffles at all."
The other Wilson sister is Mary Lila Grace,
who is also one of the nominees for Prom Queen,
although her date doesn’t seem to have a
counterpart in the book as far as I can tell.
When Billy and Chris are in the car together,
he momentarily calls her “Chucky”,
"What are you scared Chucky?"
a nickname
he uses a couple of times to get under her
skin in the novel.
Following the prom scene, there is one more
event that takes place.
Sue Snell is one of the only survivors after
losing her boyfriend and most of her classmates.
We see her come up to the destroyed remains
of the house, the soft bloom effect on the
camera is very similar to the scene where
Tommy pulls up to Carrie’s house to ask
her to the prom again, it’s very dream-like,
but this dream of Sue’s will soon become
a nightmare.
Sue brings her a bouquet of flowers as beautiful
woodwind music plays… but wait… these
are red flowers, the color of the devil.
Something is not right here.
The cars in the background are driving backwards,
one of which may be the very same car that
that Billy and Chris use to try to run over Carrie.
The religious symbols come back for one final
appearance.
The for sale sign is in the shape of a cross
with vandalism reading “Carrie White Burns
in Hell”, pointing down to the rubble, the
last remains of the house.
When Sue steps onto this rubble, something
changes.
She has entered hell.
The scene becomes even more unnerving to the
subconscious as the sky turns from blue to
black before the final horror takes place.
And if you are a fan of horror or a fan of Stephen King,
then you're gonna want to subscribe to this channel
because I've got new horrors every week including more Carrie coming,
so make sure you ring that deathbell for notifications,
head to privacy.com/czsworld to get your free five dollars,
and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.